une chose de loi devient tout de suite
c'est que je pense que c'est plus une
histoire racontée en images qu'un film
une histoire que la majorité des gens
connaissent un crime une enquête et un
procès alors on a fait une enquête le
procès mais on a une difficulté est la
difficulté la suivante entre le crime le
l'enquêté le procès ça a duré plus de
deux ans et nous enfin les auteurs et a
dit robert boulanger et galets ont été
obligés de la raconter en 2h50
alors il est évident que on a pris les
traits principaux de la faire et je
crois quand même
quelles étaient ses scrupuleusement
rendu parce que il est beau père à
naviguer au plus près comme on dit dans
la marine si on est toujours resté dans
le sujet d'ailleurs j'ai lu et relu
bouquin dieu nous et c'est ça qui m'a
incité à le faire il ya une première
partie qui sont des notes sur le procès
d'après les enquêtes et après il a
dépeint des caractères des personnages
et sata et des toits personnellement
pour le personnage de dominici je pense
oui et je propose le procès qu'ils
avaient suivi l'engin j'avais suivi
comme tout le monde dans les journaux
moi j'étais proche au pour le faire
violence et en disant le bouquin de
giono
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait quand même un
intérêt à le faire jusqu'à finalement
qu'est-ce que tu est une histoire
on n'a jamais connu les mobiles on les
connaîtra probablement jamais et puis
elle reste alors le reste au public de
juger quand tu dis que tu n'étais pas
chaud pour le faire ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que tu ne voulais pas être
gaston dominici ou simplement que c'est
le genre de film qui d'intérêt s'est
plaint non je pense que c'était très
épineux de faire cette chose là ou alors
oui et puis nous de faire cette chose là
mais de la manière dont non you know a
décrit des personnages
ça m'a incité à le faire lui tant pis
essayez il ya eu des réactions des
réactions locales et des réactions des
gens disant que c'est un film qu'on
n'aurait pas dû tourner ailleurs
important et ça y est il ya eu des
réactions locales
évidemment dans les journaux aussi enfin
dans ne donne pas tellement les journaux
certains journaux les journaux de
chantage c'est ce qu'on appelle la
liberté de la presse trop longue
chantage doit lesquels mais non la
brouille des réactions de des gens du
cru
enfin nous le film dégage resté très
digne sans nous préoccuper
elle veut dire on s'en est pas occupé on
n'a pas voulu s'en mêler on n'a pas
voulu ça ne sonne moi ça ne regardait
pas pascal lors du combat s'avère
finalement ça va très loin de l'instant
que des choses ont été écrites dont les
journaux qui ont été dévoilées qu'elles
ont été ya pas de raison que le cinéma
n'est même pas ça par là dedans et je
trouve que c'est même plus tard
jean giono écrivait j'ai demandé si ces
aveux avaient été fidèlement reproduits
au procès verbaux on m'a répondu oui
scrupuleusement
on les a seulement mis en français tous
ces personnages y en a qui existent
encore parle avec l'accent du midi ou en
provençal alors il j'allais prendre une
décision pouvait pas jouer avec l'accent
du midi ou parler en provençal
alors on a parlé comme tout le monde si
j'ose dire
mais eux et lui le le vieux gaston
parler beaucoup reprochent au salon tout
accusé disposant d'un vocabulaire de
deux mille mots seraient sortis à peu
près indemne de ce procès si en plus ils
avaient été doué du don de parole et
d'un peu d'art de récits il serait
acquitté
malgré les aveux il a été condamné à
mort et la peine était comme les autres
travaux forcés à perpétuité par le
président coty et le président de gaulle
l'a fait sortir complètement après allez
tu avais projet ont dû pas égayer vos
boîtes du inverse crever des tas bien
dormi non pourtant tu avais un lit oui
mais je me suis retourné sur vos
mensonges à tous pénalisé les nouvelles
le pompon dit les [ __ ] va me chercher
c'est devant moi pour leur cracher à la
figure c'est eux les assassins moi j'ai
pas reconnu mon père mais il m'a fait
dans l'amour livrer mes deux fils dans
l'amour moi j'aurais été je retiens
d'enfer pour mon père et une dénonce
gérard ni j'ai donné le jour à des
cochons me chercher ces charognards pas
mais chercher je vais les chercher
je veux dire une chose pour moi il n'est
pas coupable